okay so thank you very much for inviting
me this prestigious campus and uh I
would like to make some just survey of
what geometry can be used to help about
some problem tensors and mainly about
the identifiability problem uh sorry
that I will spend the first slides to
introduce some notation and this maybe
is something that everybody knows but
let me start very
quickly and this is the plan of the
talk and so what is a tensor everybody
knows what is a
tensor but say why I use this kind of
objects from my point of view the idea
is that you use matrices when you want
to relate to two different sets and you
need to use tensor when you relate three
or more
sets and my definition the first piece
of notation is that I uh will indicate
with simple a tensor which is a tensor
product of elements of vectors
essentially this is
the the notation that I will use and the
idea is that if the tensor uh is
something which gives some statistical
connection among variables then simple
means that the variables are independent
so uh well let's see that the set of
simple tensor is a cone but this is not
a Subspace and this is exactly where all
the story starts and it spans the whole
Space of tensor so everything can be
written as a sum of simple tensors and
this is the definition of rank that we
saw in the previous talk so the rank of
a tensor is exactly as everybody
knows uh let me call the summation of TI
is a decomposition of the tensor so I
will use the word decomposition both to
indicate the sum and also to indicate
every
summon and just say that if you use this
definition of tensor this is a a way to
measure the complexity of a tensor in
sense that if you have a tensor of high
rank this imply many tens of right R
imply many connections among the
variables so why use algebraic geometry
related to tensors well many interesting
set of tensors are defined by algebraic
equations uh let's say at least inside
some uh small set and so you use uh this
fact and since you have algebraic
equations then the first thing to look
at is what happens over an algebraically
closed field because the general know
sense is that algebraic equations are
easier when you have an algebraically
closed field so from this point of view
uh tensors of real numbers are
considered at the second level of
difficulty so we first start and see
what happens in the complex case and all
what I'm going to say is over the
complex
field the second idea is that well many
interesting sets of tensors as simple
tensors are cones and so uh cones means
that I they are defined by homogeneous
pols and so it's natural to factor out
the C action this maybe is one big
difference between people coming from
geometry and people coming from uh
statistics
because usually what you do when you
look at statistic you may take a
normalization of everything and you just
put the condition that the summation of
all probabilities is one what we do in
Geometry is just we don't care about
scaling a tensor so we take everything
factoring out the S action and so we go
to consider Pro tensors as F in the
projective space and more or less the
two procedure are the same so let me
take the point of view of projective
geometry uh so uh what is important
about our knowledge of tensors we take
the point of view of rank so what we
would like to know for genetic tensor of
given rank is to know the dimension of
the variety we will see that of course
everybody knows that tensils of a given
rank Define a projective variety so find
the dimension
find
equations find how many minimal
decompositions a general tensor
has and this is exactly the what I would
call the identifiability problem and for
specific tensor you would like to
compute the rank of a given tensor or
find how many minimal decompositions a
given tensor has and this is again the
identifiability problem for specific
tensor
and of course find the decomposition of
the decompositions because they could be
more than one of a given
tens and I will talk both for the
generic case and the specific case and
essentially I apologize that the word
generic in general will be synonymous in
this talk okay
so okay so what is the interpretation of
rank the interpretation of rank in the
projective word is by means of second
ver this let me start from a geometrical
point of view take any Variety in
projective space and let me start with
the abstract SEC variety which is just
the correspondence of points P1 to PK
are points in your original variety x
and q is something in the span the
linear span of P1 up to PK this is the
abser
construction and you have of course a
projection to the last factor and this
projection can be used to define the
secant varieties that you have I mean
different kind of definitions you can
Define the strict secant variety which
is just the image of the
map and so is the is defined as the set
of points such that you find independent
points next with P belong sorry this is
should be Q belongings to the span of P1
up to PK and the second variety is the
zisy closure so you can think to this as
the usual closure of the street
Cas uh so what is the relevant picture
with tensors if you take X to be the set
of simple tensors then being a point of
the two secant variety means that your
original your tensor is something of
rank two and you define rank three as
being a point in the plain span by three
simple tensors and so
on so the geometric interpretation is
that you start with the variety of
simple tensors and what is the
geometrical interpretation of the
variety of simple tensors you take uh
points of the separate product of
projective
spaces and the main fact is that as I
told you at the beginning the product of
many projective spaces is not a linear
space it can be embedded in a bigger
project space
PN and the image is called the SEC
embedding from getic point of view so
seeing the rank one tensors are points
in the SE in bending of
X and rank rank rank K tensors are
points in the street K secant variety of
the SE embedded and for points belonging
to the second variety there is the
definition of border rank which roughly
speaking means that they are limit of
rank K tens and these are of this Cas
secret so what is the geometric
translation of our
problems the problem of finding the
dimension of the variety of tensors of
given border rank is exactly find the
dimension of SEC variety of sred
varieties and find equations for secant
varieties of sacred varieties and find
the the compositions for find K points
on the S variety which span a given
point p
inside the
uh Sigma K of X and study the
identifiability find how many sets of K
points of the secret variety spend a
given set given point B in the SEC space
and we will focus on this
problem oh let's say that in my setting
how many here well I started with the
product of XK time so how many here
means mod per mutations of course you
can
permute your set of simple tensors
giving given p and so I will always talk
about mod
permutations and both for the generic
and specific case so let's see what
happens for a generic tensor or a given
rank or for a specific given
tens but is the main uh structure for
understanding problems on the SEC
variety well the main LMA is the still
the Theus LMA which tells us what is a
tangent space at the general point of
the uh secant variety and this is
exactly the tangent spaces the span of
tangent spaces to X at given point P1 up
to PK of the dec
composition it's interesting to see the
proof of the Rin is LMA because some
ideas of the proof can be used later and
this is the proof in the sense that of
course moving a point P inside the
second variety means that you want to
move the two points of the dec
composition and moving infinitesimally
the two points of the decomposition
means that you take the two tangent
vectors at the two points of the dec
composition of course you can also move
P along the second line but Al together
this gives us the uh the definition of
the span of the two tangent spaces at
the two points of the dec
composition well another proof is more
technical but very easy the UPS secant
variety is locally a product so it's
easy to understand what is the tangent
space to this abstra secant variety
points and the map AK the projection to
the last factor is generically smooth
which means that the tangent space is
Set uh isomorphically downstairs
and this is another way to understand
what the meaning of General point is in
the original statement of thein is L
which could be relevant if you want to
look at some specific
tensors well thein LMA is usually
applied as a method to compute the
dimension of the SEC variety and uh
let's say that from now on I uh assume
that the DI of my second variety
is uh the expected value and also that
this value is smaller than the dimension
of the ambient space so the second
variety is not fing is not the ambient
space and I will refer to this as the
non-defective case this is
something let's take this just as piece
of
notation but what is less uh known is
that Terin LMA can can be used also to
detect the identifiability of general
tensors and why is that uh for generic
nonidentifiability assume that you have
I mean more than one decomposition for
the general tensor I can show that what
happens in the picture so for a general
tensor you have several decompositions
okay now what happens if you move your
general tensor along the space then you
find that the new tensor still has more
than one
deos so you get that this movement
determines other sequence all than
passing through the new points but now
what happens from terin's point of
view the tangent spaces at all points in
the picture are the same in the sense
that the span of the two tangent spaces
at these two points is the same as the
span of the tangent spaces at these two
points and the same of the tangent
spaces at these two points because the
tangent space to the secant variety does
not change when you move your point
along uh a secant space and so you see
that what happens that if As you move
your point in the second space you get
in finely many be compositions all
having the same tangent space and this
is the main tool for understanding what
happens from this point of view the tool
is that you get what is called a Content
Locus what is a counta Locus a Conta
Locus is the say that comes from this
remark if a general tensor of a given
rank is not
identifiable then the general space
which is
tangent to points P1 up to PK K is two
in the
picture defines really is indeed tangent
at infinitely many points the one in the
the uh orang set and they Define a
subvariety an algebraic subvariety look
this
identifiable unique decomposition of to
trivialities or yes okay yes that's
exactly my definition up to
permutation and so you get this count
Lotus and the geometry of this cont lus
will be helpful in understanding what
happens for t
uh first remark contact Losi have the
property that they are containing many
hyperplanes if you look at the local
geometry of this content low side you
see that there are many derivatives that
must vanish along this content low side
so they are contained in many
hyperplanes they are highly
degenerate what this is the usual word
used in the algebra geometry to uh
indicate that something is contained in
a space of small
Dimension and so you have a way to
control what happens and this is indeed
the original idea of s improving that
the uh Veron variety is the unique
variety for surface for which tangent
spaces in two different points General
points
meet and the idea is that if you have a
count locus of Dimension M then this
countact Locus SP a Subspace of at most
that Dimension but the main remark is
that generic non-identifiability is stly
related with the existence of Highly
degenerate sub varieties passing through
K General points so you have both a way
to prove
that uh something is identifiable if you
can prove that there are no degenerate
subvarieties passing through General
points or if you have such kind of Degen
subvarieties you have a hint how to look
at for finding examples of nonenal
identifiability let's just use the
second approach in order to prove that
something is not generically
identifiable the first object that I
would like to present is that look that
at tensor of type 2 by 2 by two five
times Well General tensor of this type
are not
identifiable and what what is the reason
well they have exactly two
decompositions two different
decompositions and how you can prove
that well I have a geometric way to
prove this and the geometric proof of
course if you try to make experiments
you find that you find exactly that
there are two decomposition but this is
not a proof but a proof can be given by
showing that through five general points
of that separate product one can draw an
elliptic normal curve of degree 10 and
why is the reason that this is a proof
because since through five general
points there are only two in the picture
but the idea is the the same you find is
a li normal curve for lipin number curve
we know everything about secant
varieties and we know that the general
point of the span of the liting normal
curve is containing in two different
secant spaces and so this means that if
you take a general point of the second
variety of P1 cross P1 cross P1 this is
contained in the second variety of the
liid normal curve but you have two
different decompositions in the LI
normal curve so you have two different
decompositions in
the P1 cross P1 five times and the
theory gives you that EX two
decompositions so this is a proof that
you have exact at least two how do you
no no no no the point is that of course
this is not obvious from this picture
but what you find out is that every
decomposition for a general tensor every
decomposition must be one of this so you
find because otherwise you would have
another another elliptic curve and this
is false so for General T so you can
find out that exactly that number of
decompositions
well of course you have to compute
something in the sense that
sorry you have to prove that
through uh that number of points you
find exactly
one uh elliptic curve but the elliptic
curve must be contained in the count
Locus you compute the count Locus at a
given set of points and you realize that
the dimension is one so you have just
one elliptic curve and this is enough to
say that there are no other
decomposition positions and this is
enough okay let me see another statement
look at General tensor of rank six and
type 4X 4 by 4 even in that case you
find non generic identifiability so
indeed they have exactly two
decompositions and once again all the
stuff is to prove the existence of an
elliptic normal curve tic normal curve
are really something which appear uh
which appears a lot of time in these
kind of computations uh almost all
examples that I know of generic
nonidentifiability are related with the
existence of elliptic normal objects
except one example that I will show you
later and even in that case you find an
example look I mean these are quite I
mean more cases in which talking about
tensor this is a 4x4 by four tens if you
look at three variables with four states
and you look at the Matrix of
this three variables they could be three
positions in the DNA chain and you find
that something of General object of rank
six which means that you have six
different kind of
uh I mean kind of dnas and you look at
three positions you cannot divide the
tensor in the three original tensil
giving you
the your object because you have exactly
two possibilities for that so it sounds
like it sounds odd but it turns out it
is an example what about rank four 4X
4x4 rank four that's of course for 4X
4x4 and rank four of this is covered by
other kind of theorems so six is exactly
the case that you do not know I mean if
you look for instance there are other
kind of I will talk this about this
later there are other kind of these are
negative results I show you some
positive results and if you look for
instance at
Cru uh I mean Criterion then this is
covered by Cru criteria for generic
things but not for specific one of
course
you let me mention that the existence of
a count long because unfortunately does
not necessarily imply the
nonidentifiability it's a little bit
more complicated the existence of an
elliptic curve as a contact Locus imply
implies though nonidentifiability but
this is false for instance if your cont
Locus is what is called a
k is one apparent double point which
means that the count the the general
point in the span
of the contact Locus is containing just
one SE space and there are varieties
which are known to be this kind of
objects rational noral curves General
Arrangements of linear spaces and we
know everything about OAS surfaces if
your contact so having a contact Locus
is not enough to decide that the tensor
is the general tensor is not
identifiable you need to know that the
contact Locus is not of this type and
elliptic curv curves are not of this
type so you can
conclude and
indeed if your contact Locus is an OAS
then the converse Als in that case if
the contact the contact L is really
responsible for giving the
decompositions all the
decompositions come from the Conta Locus
so if the contact Locus has more than
one decomposition say in the case of
elliptic curve tic curves then you know
that the general identifiability fails
but if the contact lus is in O as then s
is generically so
this you're missing a uh so X is K
generically identifiable or yes that's
the statement K generically identifiable
sometimes K is missing in some statement
apologize for
that uh let me also mention before going
to positive results that there is a
Bound for what you can find out with
this stuff of contact L side and the
fact is that there is a maximum for
which you can imagine to understand
identifiability and the maximum is given
from that formula where n is the
dimension of the second variety and uh
capital N is the dimension of the total
space of of tensors and the reason for
that is that when you take the
projection from the Absa secant variety
if the dimension of the abst variety is
bigger than the dimension of the target
space of course the fiber cannot find it
and so I mean you have a maximum number
for
identifiability and with this this
maximum number you can compute this
number quite easily this is the maximum
for which you can imagine to have
genetic identifi
and let me uh say that it may happen
that this is an integer and when this is
an integer of course this is exactly the
maximum possible value for generic
identifiability and unfortunately we
cannot handle with the K with the stuff
of contact low side we cannot handle in
that case the maxim fork okay so there
is some case can which cannot be uh by
now let we say by now cannot
be considered from this point of view
but now uh let the general nonsense is
that when K is
small you have ways to understand what
happens for
identifiability when K grows and
approaches this maximal value Things
become much more complicated and let's
so State positive results in terms of
how far are you from this maximal B
so yes K bigger than this number is it
not Iden well depends because
essentially I
mean you cannot use this kind of this
kind of arguments essentially this Isa
so the contact Locus cannot be used
that's the point of course you may
imagine I have no examples of
identifiable cases where the rank is
bigger than the maximum border
rank if you have one please tell me
that's so I mean but in principle it may
happen that you have only one DEC
composition if the r is bigger than the
maximum possible border rank why not I
mean sound sounds really strange but it
could happen and you cannot use this
kind of method to understand what
happens in this
situation so let's see what happens for
the first case take
10 2 by 2 by two certain number of times
here K Max is that number
there theorems about this
situation well for defectivity
everything is known the dimension of the
SEC varieties are always what you
expect but let's look what happens for
identifiability well there is a result
by 2005 saying that such product is
identifiable when the number of factors
is much bigger than the than the rank
okay and you can refine this that is a
refinement by Alman Matias Roots saying
a precise boundary for Bound for how
much is s is bigger than K and this is
what they find which is about the square
root of K Max /
2 using contact Losi you find and the
shable result which is that K is less or
equal
than essentially the maximum value
divided by two and if you refine the
method of uh
uh C low side you are much much closer
to the maximal value this is the
original statement and with new ideas
for computations you can get even closer
and maybe then now if you just let your
computer run then you can get much much
closer but I will show you why and just
to mention oh
maybe go
back this
is and just to mention the method for
the first result in this setting is
quite easy if you use the non uh the
fact that something is not defective and
you use the translation of this fact in
the setting of contact low side then
it's almost immediate to see that you
get the K Max divided by two and this is
always true
essentially but in order to refine that
well there are other sharper things that
you can do for instance you can try to
use some inductive
procedure uh so an idea is to you
consider the product of p1's as a family
of products one factor less and
as parameterized by P1 this is the idea
okay so let's consider the last Factor
as as a base for a family and then you
push the K points to the two copies of
the smaller product and you want to use
induction if you know everything about s
minus one copies then you can try to
push what you know for s- y copies to
the higher situation just in order to
prove that there is no contact lock
assume that you know that there is no
count Locus for S minus one
copies and you want to push this fter
you can do that except that of course
contact Locus means here to be tangent
to the smaller product and you have to
know what happens if you go to the
bigger product you have to control what
happens this can be done because the
structure of a secret product is locally
indeed quite easy to understand and if
you do that you find out this is a a
method introduced for defectivity by Abu
utani and peton
okay and this is uh how you get this
result let me just just explain the uh
this strange number appearing over there
well it depends just on the your initial
step because you know that for five
copies you have not generic
identifiability so what is the initial
step you can do something by looking at
six copies seven copies and so on and
you have to do that by hand just using a
computer to prove that there is no
contact Locus and you can do that to
some extent and if you use 10 copies of
P1 the best that you can do is that you
arrive to this strange factor of course
this is these are powers of
two
and uh if you do that for be a computer
algebra p package well may be that with
a large computer you can go a little bit
fter but things become really odd and
you need some new idea and using a
different approach that we explain in
minutes then you can get even closure to
the wol range I should say that it would
be great to have a
complete uh description for the case of
many copies of P1 but unfortunately we
are not able to do the last step so at
any time that you have uh basis for your
induction then you lose something and
what you lose is exactly the remaining
uh coefficient that you see
there uh of course these two results
together uh suggest the
conjecture that the case of five copies
of P1 is exactly the last case of many
copies of P1 in which you get generic
nonidentifiability
and for tensors of type A cross B Cross
C some known result is Cru theor
everybody knows about Cru CL theorum
people working in this kind of uh
problem and there is a bound which is
almost linear say in terms of the rank
and in terms of a b and
c uh in the unbalance case you can do
much better the unbalance case is the
case where uh
essentially this means that c is much
bigger than a and b if you look at it
carefully and there are other kind of uh
results in this setting but let see what
happens if you use the uh the process of
contact LW side in order to find results
in this
setting and for a cont well for let's
say
geometric let's say what happens if you
use some geometric tool then this this
paper by Sten famous paper by Sten in
which at a certain point says that using
geometric ways and make some
computations and these computations are
really very algebraic so you may wonder
why you have a geometry it says that
this is a geometric way to produce kind
of result and what he produces in the
case is that K
identifiability holds for OD C and this
bound here oh
sorry which is very close to the maximal
value very very close and indeed you can
interpret the str's original argument in
terms of contact L ey and maybe this is
this was exactly what he had in mind in
writing down this kind of theorem and if
you do that in terms of contact you see
immediately that there is no point
in saying that c must be odd for any c
you find the same exactly the same
Bal and for the unbalanced case when C
is much bigger than you have other kind
of statements still using contact L side
that you can draw immediately in that
case if unbalance imbalance is not so
clear what is the meaning of unbalance
let's say that this is a definition
which is different from the definition
of theot over and domov but in that case
you have a complete descrition if and
all if or generic
identify and say that in the balance
case you we have a complete picture up
to uh this product up to is 50,000 maybe
maybe even more because uh computers are
running okay so let me give another
example of nonidentifiability and the
examples are tensors of rank 8 and TI 3x
6X 6 in this case they have six
different DEC compositions the general
tensor of that
type and the contact Locus now is not an
elliptic curve but is much more
complicated is a product is another seg
product embedded in the original seg
product by a strange device and is not
clear to me you can compute and you find
that there exist this lus you you find
this from your computer for a specific
case then you have to prove this in
general you can do that but don't ask me
why in this particular case there is
this strange subvariety here what is the
meaning an elliptic curve is quite clear
is it really 113 not 311 311 oh sorry
sorry sorry sorry sorry yes in this
setting is
112 So it t of type 22 3 here sorry this
is related to no it's the the divisor is
bothering me because the P2 should have
a different embedding than the p 2 P1
should have the same embedding mhm so
that they should be the ones if three is
correct because otherwise no no so how
is1 playing how is I show you the proof
C I mean you see that you can embed one
one with P1 cross P2 and one one with P1
cross P2 2 and then P2 itself though
this means that three is related to
P2 okay and you do that sorry the point
is that this three is related to P2 yeah
that's that's I okay yes yes sorry I'm
it was wrong right
okay and there is strong I don't know
how many decompositions are there in
that case there is strong evidence by
computer that there are exactly six de
compositions but in this case I cannot
prove
is this the maximum possible value for
tensors of type A cross B Cross C for
which you have not identifiability for
General tensors I don't know there
evidence for
that and everything here can be
rephrased when you take more factors so
you have a formula let's say what
happens for the very balanced cubic case
you have a formula which is about some
uh fraction of the maximum value and for
the unbalance case you have still if and
only if still using
CS let me uh point out some
computational aspect how you can produce
this kind of results so how you can go
up to this number here and up to this
number
here but a way to do that is to look at
the contact Locus and of course if the
contct locus is positive dimensional you
have a tangent space to the C locks so
if you can prove that there is no
tangent space B to the contact logos
then you can prove that the contact SOS
can not
exist and this is the way you you can
perform this computations
because usually when you take a SE
product being tangent means that you
contain the uh coordinate spaces and you
can prove and you can try to show what
happens if you extend this property to
uh infinitesimally closed
points and this happens to you make
computations and what you find out is
this what is called the station Matrix
which is a block Matrix where Q is any
linear equation for a k tangent space
you start with a k tangent space in a
set of points and look at uh any linear
equations and this UI s are local
coordinates for any copy of your
coordinate spaces inside the SE product
so it's a very linear algebraic kind of
MX that you can uh can consider and if
the rank of the stack Edition is maximum
for all possible equations Q of your K
tangent space at one point of the
decomposition of a general tensor then
you find that generic K identifiability
alss because there is no uh contact
Lockers in that
and now computations can be performed by
linear algebra and they're much faster
than in the case of uh
um uh symbolic algebra packages and this
is why you can go up to
50,000 uh for specific tensors well for
specific tensors you have a way use to
use count Lui even for specific pencils
but except that you need one more
condition and why is that this is due to
the zisy main theor assume that t is a
smooth point of the SEC
variety if the general fiber is given by
permutation so it's
trival so this means that genetic Tor is
identifiable and sub fiber at some
specific point is not a singlet model of
permutations which means that some
specific tensor is not identifiable by
this risky main
theorem the general the fiber over T is
positive dimensional so at your T Locus
exists and
so and so what you do is that if you can
say that your original tensor is smooth
inside the second variety then the stack
editions give you uh computation for
identifiability Let me Give an example
take this tensor of T 5x 5 by five you
can compute this this is a smooth point
of the SEC variety because fortunately
you know many local equations of that
secant variety and so you compute the
tangent space of those equations and
this is the same Dimension so what you
get is that this is a smooth point and
now you compute the stack evation and
you find an
identifi let me just observe that this
tensor is beyond cral
range surely what happens for symmetric
tensor you can use tations for symmetric
tensor and to find symmetric
identifiability which is the the
composition in symmetric tensors of rank
one and there is a new example of
non-general identifiable tensors that
came out from stad
computations and this is the case and
once again uh uh this is due to
existence of the contact Locus which
again is a li normal curve let me say
that this is not well known in the sense
that well the
ex classically they had all the
ingredients to compute that except that
they did not did not observe that the
general cubic of rank nine had had that
structure and so in certain sense this
is something new and for symmetric
tensors we know almost everything
because there is a t balico for genetic
identifiability that says what happens
when you have more than uh um three
copies of your tensors and for matrices
of course matrices are almost never uh
they are almost never defective so
identifiability cannot hold and so it
remains to understand what happens for
three copies which means cubics and for
cubics we know almost everything uh
except for one case and and see that
this is working PR us if may I have one
minut more sure this is the last
slide and in the last slide let me open
some other perspectives of using
geometry for understanding tensors one
is a systematic study of singularities
of SEC varieties at least in the case of
seg varieties which means homogeneous
varieties you cannot control
singularities of SEC varieties in
general because everything may happen
but for very homogeneous spaces like SE
varieties you may hope to have a
description of the singular Locus
together with the station this give a
condition for computing the identifiable
of
tens uh then let me mention that for the
case of symmetric tensor there are
methods for detecting the
identifiability this is would be another
talk so I mean I don't want to enter
there but if you look carefully and you
use carefully the hbert function then
there are papers by lansburg and binski
there are papers by the balik and
Bernardi and probably I my my feeling is
that uh full strength of the ilber
function is not yet been used to write
down
uh theorems
are what happens for identifiability of
symetric tensors even for specific
symetric tensors but this is working
Province to and then you can look at
identifiability ofous systems of tensors
so you take a linear system of tensors
and you want to take the simultaneous
decompositions of the elements and this
can be stud is still with this method of
content Locus because it can be
rephrased in terms of the
identifiability of bigger tenses and
then there is another point you can
change your definition of simple tensors
simple tensors for rank one yes okay but
why there could be other kind of of
simple tensors for instance if you look
at the symmetric case simple tensors are
powers of linear forms but if you ask to
students of the first year then a
monomial which is not simple from that
point of view but it's very simple at
the first side I mean you are very
excited when you see a monomial and then
so you can change your definition of
simple tensors and you can ask the same
and I think that geometric matters for
other kind of simple tensors definitions
are not
used at all and so this is a word of
theorems and that's an important
St
questions for
Luka so the thing is uh uh one possible
definition of simple tenses for
symmetric tenses is that instead of a
you could have uh uh you know
symmetrizes right so the r is there some
is there anything know in that case I I
mean of course there are things that are
know for the identifiability because
they're General but I think that the
full strength of what you can do using
geometric methods that like this method
of the c l c l means that you use some
differential geometry you look at the
infinitees of deformations okay and I
think that there is space for finding
out other results this is what I have in
mind but even for instance for Gen I
mean other case of there is a recent
paper by Seth salivan about the mixtures
of several models of Mark of
trees and what happens if you try to
understand the identifiability of mixes
by using Conta GL ey what is the tangent
space of that gloss ey who knows I mean
I never saw a specific approach from
this point of view maybe it gives some
new
results I
see for the
nonidentifiable case U are there some
thing known on the degree or the well
Dimension if you have if you have the if
you have an elliptic normal curve you
you can say the degree is to because you
know everything about the degree of an
eliptic no Cur the second degree or what
we call the second order but for the
case for instance of tensors of type 3x
6X 6 we have the strong feeling that the
second order is six is six okay and if
you try with the computer their p is
package is very clever in finding out
many decompositions of a given T so you
find yourself with of them but this is
not enough of course it may be that if
you let your computer run for one
billions of years he finds another
decomposition somewhere and so uh
essentially the the the the number of
different decompositions that you find
are the number of different
decomposition of the content logos so
just to look at the cont logos what
happens in that case the cont lus
however gives you the
number
so in case you have something in a
generic identifiable case is it is it
easy to describe what the exceptional
set is so it does not at all not at all
for instance this is one part of this
kind of problem you expect that when you
have
singularities this comes because you
have two different points of the ABS and
variety patching together when you
project that now but is this possible
what happens in that case I don't know
so it would be great even to bound to
have equations just one equation give me
one
equation of the locus where your uh your
set jumps and unfortunately this is this
exactly uh related to my first question
can you give some criteria for the case
of uh symmetric tensors you have some
criteria saying that in this open subset
you cannot have anything because for
if you know a specific
decomposition and you look at the points
of the specific decomposition that you
have these are points in the Veron
variety go back to your original
projective Spin and look at the ilber
function of those points if the ilber
function of those points is generally
enough and the rank is not too big then
you can conclude and is not even written
down in the complete generality I
know I guess that there are more results
on that but anyway you can conclude that
the of points is is good so for instance
one equation would be that your there is
a one de composition for which the
pre-image in your original projective
space has a general Hilbert function
this is for the symmetric case what can
be done for the general case I don't
know what is the analog of the ilber
function in the non symmetric
case there is a very recent paper
introducing a sort of ilber function for
the nonsymmetric case but we know very
very small things about what happens in
the non symmetric case this is some
propaganda I mean this is a word of De
and
so it's a very good
point sense whether these results and
identifiability could be made robust in
the following sense suppose you look at
tensors over real numbers mhm then um
your entries are
real if you know that so you have a t
here it would be nice to say that you
know in a small region around it
decompositions of those are also close
to the decomposition I agree that every
problem
about commands like
conjectures can be easier if you you you
know identifiability of course because
in that case usually when you have
identifiability it could be easier to
understand if you start with a tensor of
a certain type you want to understand
understand if all the possible
decompositions are of that type and if
have one decomposition then probably
this is a good point but they have not
general statement about that however I I
think that there is something is there
well anyway the if the stack is maximal
rank this is true on maybe
was yes for general for
General I see so if you proved
identifiability VI the then that would
automatically imply some kind of robust
identifi yes or no the problem is that
it depends if your original tensor is
generally enough so for instance it may
happen that well this can not happen but
anyway let's see what happens if you
take that specific over a finite
field let's say the all tensors with
entries in that finite field are
singular points of the second right so
what I mean in that case you the
Stacked cannot give an answer you have
to know two things St of maximal rank
and a smooth point of SEC if you have
both then it is it hold in an open
subset yeah so then if I choose my low
rank penser from some distribution some
sort oficially random distribution then
would it if you believe that this is a
good point of Cru scale is about three
over two I think with this technique we
can arrive at two instead of three over
two so a bit more but uh there are no
equation of SEC variety higher so look I
mean assume that you have a point and
you have a
decomposition which means the SEC
space and if you have some continuous
set of DEC compositions and the stack
evation gives you an
answer but if you have just one
decomposition here and another
decomposition around Saturn say I mean
how can you know that this is not the
case this is singular point in the SEC
ver
so I mean your specific tensor in that
case is not enough you have to know that
this is not a a singular point if this
is true then the station can give you an
answer so I should also add that on
Friday we're going to have a a lot of
discussion on identifiability from point
of view and you will probably be
interested it come the talks on Friday
so let's thank Luka again for
wonderful
so